and welcome to punch-drunk sports where
winners win ah joining us returning
sugars we started yeah we did start
welcome returning champion uh he's still
in town they haven't ran him out yeah
Chad sumac everybody how's it going
punch-drunk listeners I'm back I lost a
thousand dollars yeah Chad tell us the
story of how you lost a thousand dollars
I had to give my friend a thousand
dollars cuz I owed him a thousand
dollars so I gave him the money no I got
out of the bank yeah and and from the
bank until when I saw him I lost a
thousand dollars I looked everywhere I
don't know if it fell out of my pocket
it was an envelope thousand dollars is
gone he's just going somebody needs that
money more than you did dude you are an
angel
yeah angel in the centerfold am i right
guys
where about did you lose it give me like
a ballpark somewhere between you can do
a little investigating I'm just gonna go
you know root around do some rooting
around you know what's funny though can
I say something before we get started no
doubt okay go ahead my listener okay I
actually I used to have a joke or one
time I went for a walk I was like
wouldn't be cool if I found a thousand
dollars just a thought but what I
started doing I started looking around
for a thousand dollars that done it
doesn't exist and before I could stop
myself a guy stops and goes dude what
are you looking for I was like a
thousand dollars he's like are you
serious I'm like you want to make 500
now he's looking around for a thousand
dollars and I don't know how to get out
of this so I mean dude your riches [ __ ]
bail right you have that fat cash well
yeah I mean I'm a yeah I've been selling
ah Mirjana road
right right I am oh I do I don't spend a
lot of money I'm able to do this cuz I
save you're like one of these guys are
just like knows how to game the road
right you'll give free hotel rooms yeah
right you'll meet some local bang her
and she'll cook food for ya the road
works for me I don't work for the road I
like that a lot hey where you gonna be
Chad you got any dates coming up yeah
I'm gonna be at the DC comedy loft I'm
gonna be there headline
December or anybody 15 that's [ __ ] up
for December 14 15th and yeah go to my
Instagram Chad's ooh mock but you know
who else is here the host of the show
Jason Tebow hi guys I will be nowhere
soon
don't come watch me Sam what about you
hey I'm going to this Thursday night its
third eye comedy at the dojo
we've got jimmy dore oh you're doing a
show we said no it's not Thanksgiving
night Thursday this Thursday is
Thanksgiving Thanksgiving I did I really
do know it's Wednesday night oh yeah
yeah that says tomorrow night it's third
eye comedy third eye comedies tomorrow
night come down rock out rock rock rock
Third Eye Blind gonna play yes Third Eye
Blind is playing third eye comedy and
it's gonna be a great show it's only ten
bucks
you can grab that on Eventbrite and then
the following day
are the following Tuesday it is comedy
chaos at the Comedy Store it's a
wonderful lineup we've got Felipe
Esparza
jessimae Peluso Rory Scovel ah Brandon
shop and drumroll please making his
stand-up debut at the Comedy Store
Michael Rapaport so and we're gonna be
adding more names as we go so go check
that out that's comedy chaos this should
sell out for sure and then December 15th
I am at it's tin foil hat live at Zanies
in Chicago that's right Saturday Late
Late Late Show
we're doing these Late shows home which
uh which one old town and the good one
where's rose my old town I don't know
which one I got I looked that up yeah
there's a three of them the good one
they're all good the good a good one
well they go to the gooder good one hey
everybody my special zero [ __ ] dropped
two days ago it you can get on V mo B me
oh okay vimeo.com backslash on-demand
backslash zero Fox it's a dollar 99 to
rent or $2.99 to own
holla - boy hit me up let me know check
it out please support this stuff I
believe that people will start putting
out their specials the way they did
podcasting I know it's a little more
expensive but I think people are just
gonna be tired of uh being told the
rules and all that stuff so just go out
there and support it this is the first
one it odd this one's 35 minutes and
then the next one I'm dropping November
December 14th is uh like 45 minutes and
that is my Christmas special I got to
tell you Sam I am NOT just saying this
as a friend I bought the special to
support you did a phenomenal job you do
a great job it's very funny it looks
great has that cool vibe because it's at
the Viper Room so I definitely recommend
it so like I said it what you said two
dollars to buy that's cheaper than a Bud
Light it happened yeah right yeah it's
like I went cheap on it I went really
cheap fork over the cash come on be a
part help me out special help me help
you help me help you
especially the guy who has my thousand
dollars by DIY couple he should buy it
like eight hundred times she should buy
in bulk you should buy it a lot Chad did
you just I would just start walking
backwards I wish I could do that in life
and just find out what I wish you could
do I got breaking news unfolded breaking
news excited for this according to Joe
Vardhan of the athletic JR Smith will
stay away from the Cavs while the team
works to trade him to where they don't
know but he's not going to be with the
team and how can you just not play I
just think this is ridiculous they're
gonna negotiate this man like if you
don't play and you're healthy yeah you
should you shouldn't get paid yeah
exactly I like Kyrie Irving was I'm not
happy trade me or I'm not gonna play you
guys at work I don't know man I mean
lady and Bell did that and he didn't
make a buck yeah he lost 15 mill yeah
yeah I mean whose guy they say that he
might go to Jets Jets Raiders Niners
also or in the minute
I mean like they have a really expensive
quarterback don't they I mean if you
have a really expensive quarterback can
you have really expensive running back
yeah it's just you you know comes from
somewhere you know you just have a
[ __ ] really inexpensive defense I
don't know why the Browns thing go for I
guess they like Chubb huh chubbs good
jobs good is he as E as good as uh well
I mean who is Gurley that's about it
well that guy on the Steelers right now
is killing it yeah he's doing good
I think he's doing better than Bell he's
comparable his numbers are comparable
yeah so that is how come they never call
people's system running backs I mean
he's a good running back he'd probably
be good just about anywhere he was at
right you know I mean there's a reason
they drafted him last year cuz they saw
this coming so you know you draft a god
it's like hey this guy can play in our
system but I don't think any running
back does great in Pittsburgh you know I
mean I don't think I don't think it's
that type of system just like I don't
think any quarterback can plug in and do
what Brady does yeah I mean they say
Brady's a situational system quarterback
I don't think so I think he's just so
[ __ ] God among men yeah I don't think
so either I think he's good enough that
they can have all these I don't say
shitty receivers but you know everybody
that plays played receiver for them his
entire career other than Randy Moss and
Gronk whenever he's healthy journeyman
yet none of them are like Pro Bowl like
guys are just kickin world beaters that
never had an Antonio Brown or a Julio
Jones or a you know one of those guys
it's always just like a bunch of [ __ ]
Chris Huggins who where do they spend
their money cuz their defense is never
that great e Brady dough takes doesn't
give them a little break not much not
much now that he's a little bit older I
think but he's always been he always
took a pay cut though yeah he always did
after getting a huge pay raise yeah he
plays two years for [ __ ] 18 million
dollarsí and then he's like alright yeah
we need a receiver Oh how's Josh great
ago [ __ ]
he's gay I think he's gonna blow up
there but he's not he's doing alright I
think yeah I think I was like two
touchdowns there since he's been there
for four weeks
he's always banged up it he's a weird
guy he's got all the skills in the world
I know and just I know that's why the
Browns held on him for so long he was
like a hot chick and we're like yeah I'm
gonna come around and she never did
exactly what but it's exactly what he is
I mean dude when you find out that they
were even considering Condoleezza Rice
as a head coach that was bull that was
all fake news had why why would that be
fake news why would that come out
because everyone just throws out stuff
they want page clicks they just want to
click that's the dumbest thing I've ever
heard my life it's so that there's no
way that's even remotely real how does
that come out then I think how does
everything come out a list they're done
no way okay there's no way that's
exhaust there's no way that's even
remotely real oh I also heard the date
that the Chicago Bears were thinking of
having grimace as a head coach yeah
grimace click on that everybody I mean
this dude what would she know about
football
ah ESPN was reporting it just all over
the place York Post ESPN says dumb [ __ ]
bleach bleacher report was reporting it
they did a segment on it yeah I don't
even know how this chick is allowed to
walk the earth all let alone coach a
sport she's never coached if you know
reason why she's not doing it now why
because Hillary Clinton's taking over
she's gonna interview for the Browns
Haute
coaching position yeah getting political
Hey equality is important you know women
can be war criminals too yeah that's
what I gotta say that's why I love about
chicks they're like if women ran
everything there be no more Wars
Oh Condoleezza Rice Hillary Clinton
let's just Madeleine Albright let's just
keep going Margaret Thatcher we'll just
keep going I love my Bronx get the [ __ ]
on why do you hate her so much because
she's a [ __ ] war criminal who lied us
in tono she's a black woman you're
erasing you you're racist yeah that's
like a distant 47
if she was a white male you would
totally love him yeah I was like they're
like George Bush and Dick Cheney are
gonna run the Browns I would celebrate
that probably your honor she's never
coached football in general why would
they consider for a head coaching
position she ever thrown a football send
this [ __ ] into the kitchen go make me a
sandwich woman stay away from our
football if a woman is ever where's the
camera which is going right here if a
woman is ever an NFL coach I will kill
myself stay out of our football wait you
think that I don't end it every every
NFL team hires a woman just I kill
myself as a female do you disagree with
Jason Tebow go no I feel like to me do
it like teaching football what I have no
idea yeah chicks always [ __ ] it's like
why is this chick calling this game it's
annoying
yeah women say it all the time I mean
there are some that I think are good
yeah there are Erin Andrews is good
knowledgeable sideline report talking uh
when they have like women doing
play-by-play yeah on sports
some people get annoyed by it I don't
mind it it depends but it's same thing
for me like there's guys that suck like
I did several women I'd rather hear than
Cris Collinsworth cons which drives me
up a holler on them right now uh what's
her Suzy what's her face for me as soon
as he what's her face talking about what
she's yeah Suzy what's her face and a
Polish name what's your favor what's
your last name that's it yeah yeah Suzy
Kolber he's better than Collinsworth uh
who else who else
belladonna right the porn star I'd like
to hear her talk about no no no
now-now-now him Allie LaForce oh you
mean just women in general I think
masters whose calling games she's better
than he is in my opinion I actually
would like to hear even your she is a
sideline reporter but so is Colbert a
lot of times uh Erin Andrews I think is
better than [ __ ] Cris Collinsworth he
just drives me nuts well it's always
wrong and then he'll see something
that's totally wrong the next play will
happen and prove him wrong I'm well what
are you gonna do it's like everything he
says is [ __ ] either wrong or it's
about himself when he's excited company
man for sure oh you know who also is is
not that great that he's new at it
Oh Caitlyn Jenner Jason will Witten
Witten's go not that good yeah he's not
know who is Romo's good you know I think
Romo has a good future in this yeah you
know else is good uh not not Ryan but
his brother what's his brother's name
wreck booger McFarlane no look at
McFarlane jives me nuts
booger McFarlane you know mad they are
at him at that that moving thing I would
be so [ __ ] pissed off what you know
they have this like giant like Cher
thing the poker MacFarlane sits in and
it goes all up and down the field
oh my right in front of your [ __ ]
expensive ass seats so and so they can
just go interview them so you're sitting
right here and all sudden here's the
[ __ ] booger McFarlane stupid ass
sitting in a giant chair yeah that that
goes and it rotates all up and down and
follows the game Fox booger make fun I
would be so booger dude if I paid
[ __ ] what $275 a ticket for two
tickets yeah and this [ __ ] is
sitting right in front of me so ESPN can
cut to him and ask him what the [ __ ] he
thinks about the game I'm surprised he
hasn't been hit by [ __ ]
yeah book of work farlands a weird name
yeah it's just an awful name booger it's
like you're a professional person is
what I'm the original Irish
what it's from the original Irish booger
MacFarlane okay all right what about
booger from Revenge of the Nerds that's
what I'm thinking what's his real name
ass [ __ ] okay Anthony look how big his
head is yeah I'm doing that that guy
looks like a milk dud he played under
Gruden
me yeah did he won a Super Bowl explains
it yeah he did yeah it's like who gives
a flying [ __ ] yeah what Pinker [ __ ]
MacFarlane thinks just keep trying to
come up with new [ __ ] and it just blows
up in their face I don't think we've
ever said this on this show before but
I'm gonna go ahead and say it
[ __ ] ESPN they're so bad we only say it
every week do you remember the glory
days the ESP a I of course it was the
bass glory hole days yeah yeah magic
Craig Craig Kilborn did she do stand-up
on his show once yeah I killed it they
all they uh yeah there used to be great
I guess what happened what women no
money
sue yes he came and bought it and just
wrecked it and they even just came out
and said that we realize our political
talk has ruined our ruin the channel the
brand yeah the brand is done because
it's one-sided political yeah it's not
both side if you let both sides argue
people with does it that it should not
be political talk at all right I got
that is the reason that we loved it
because we could go and watch ESPN and
not have to hear all the other [ __ ]
rhetorical [ __ ] that you're getting
bombarded with all the time and now it
is that it worse for sure well how do
you want your sports where do you get it
from where do you go with your main
source well it depends what sport it is
but pretty much like reliable like for
like pro football talk is great for
football news but it's not a show it's
in that something that's filled with
commercials you know you have to like go
on the internet to a trustworthy site
yeah that is neutral yeah that's just
gonna give me the news without filling
it up with a bunch of [ __ ] kids with
no arm shooting free throws I don't care
I'm really over that times over it ESPN
did a segment SportsCenter about a
woman's basketball team that had won in
like three years
why are they on SportsCenter why why you
sure that wasn't a 3430
no yeah I mean that's
it's just unbelievable dude it's really
unbelievable
it's I don't know man what about Jim
Rome Rackham what happened to him is he
alive he's probably alive I don't know
where he's in Rome
unbelievable keeps falling farther and
farther away the show was huge back in
the day yeah it was a very big show yeah
do you know that they wanted him to UM
do it live like Colin coward
what happened but he he reads up he
reads his script
oh it's all and then he just recycles
the show he does like this shows what
three hours long he'll do like an hour
and a half of content and then just talk
about the first hour let's go to the
phones clones yeah Jim Steve Burbank
what's your take what's your take
rack'em you came in and brought the
Thunder and left toast let's talk about
it
rack'em who does like butter on their
toast Rackham unbelievable would you get
attack now we're both 'yes' Christ looks
like he's trying to kill it you know you
got to slit it this that's why I'm still
here let's go to the slam man Jay Mohr
Jay you remember Jay Mohr would fill in
for Jim Rome what are we doing a stunt
we're gonna do rob a bank how come I'm
not in surprise arrest water I'll get
off the microphone right here if it's a
cool guest I'll get off the mic
apparently here's where we go to jail
apparently here's we're about to go to
jail because apparently you're the
problem you'll be like gross or
something I will not you just said women
I don't even got it all talking you can
just rack'em good take ah a third grader
wants to come in and interview us for a
school project and I'm not joking is
that really good what's going on at
tonight that's the rumor I thought it'd
be like Bill burr or something kid rack
up what is going on in the middle of our
show that's what I was talking about
boners get it all out of you everybody
get it audio system
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] turds titties bubu see oh
I'm scared here it comes here it comes
y'all get out okay nobody asked me it's
just I don't know please sit down thank
you for coming up on sport neither do we
sweetie do we my listening for six years
how old are you
well first tell us your name hi Lucy
hi Lucy so what are you doing today oh
this is awesome
and what's the project about comedy oh
you all know about comedy well you've
come to the wrong place there's a couple
better place you gone but this will do
so what would see you got questions you
got it you're doing out like a book
report or presentation on comedy
[Music]
presentation PowerPoint all right sam
tripley's new special so by the way
you're already doing better than Chad as
again yeah you're way more talkative
chad has way better than Chad you are a
natural at this city yes exactly
oh my god boo my god so uh so what's
this presentation you're doing what they
tell you to do something on but what are
you supposed to do about and why'd you
pick comedy I like it
who's your favorite comedian
you don't have one yet you're kind of
used to back you won't after this
interview either I think you're gonna be
a cat Williams fan that's what I think
yeah trust me you're gonna love it here
I love it
ah so what questions you have for us
chef president I mean what I do - well
no there we go so you have questions and
you're what are your gonna are you gonna
write them down or you need a pen you
got a good man yeah make sure you are
just yeah
don't let early yeah that resume right
before yeah jayson's take I should note
I legally can't be this close to a child
so so uh okay so let's do this I'm
excited I'm excited
do you like stand-up comedy do you like
comedy in general yeah do you like what
you have favorite like TV show comedies
really okay sometimes my dad will be
watching something and then they'll
start laughing and then in my head I
feel like why are you laughing
oh yeah it's like maybe I don't
understand it you don't understand it
yeah I don't understand how it's funny
yeah that's great that's very analytical
of you that's a very smart thought
that's why you have to ask these
questions to figure it out right well
edit that out so uh so okay got
questions well answer employer
wait who's answering you will yeah well
I'm going to answer all of them how you
come up with jokes oh that's a great
question you take that one basically the
best way to come up with jokes is just
things that happen to you in your life
you try to find what the funny isn't it
right do you ever go to school and then
the teacher does something funny right
he does something weird though you pick
something in your life and you see and
you try to make it funny so if your
friend died you try to make that funny
no not everything depends on the vine
let me just tell you I would try I would
try I have a lot of friends it'll be
hilarious yeah yeah yeah like what's
some in your life that's funny
do you have a funny teacher someone who
does something funny is there sown in
your class it does something that you
think is like that's so weird
really you'll find it you'll find it
you're doing great you get it from your
life that's the best do they talk about
their life and they and then there's
some people who who make up weird stuff
they're called are all comics and
they're bad people make sure you know
that you'll get points when you say all
people are bad never like Patton Oswalt
okay stop okay so that's how you do it
like something uh if you're driving in
traffic or the the cafeteria ladies mean
you joke about how mean she is you know
or the school bus yeah you know you ride
on the school bus and the bus drivers
always saying doing the same dumb Joe
you do joke about that and then some of
us do like jokes about how we've
completely flame throughout our lives
it's like different things a lot a lot
of us do those jacks so that's how you
do it alright you know silver robot guy
next question you are right you're
already doing better than everybody in
the room
right why do you do comedy why do I do
comedy I lost a bet I don't know what
his story is
I do comedy cuz I literally have nothing
else ah it's the only thing I'm good as
being funny so I'm making like I'm a
making tens of dollars doing this so
it's I'm living the dream you know say
you're just doing it for the money
oh man you are good you are good you are
good are we dating all right no
basically no you don't get into comedy
for the money
have you seen their patreon no you don't
do for the money but money's fun I mean
it's good to have money right you wanted
money so you can buy things and have
nice things and live a comfortable life
so you just do i I mean I loved comedy I
think we all love making people laugh
it's a really wonderful feeling it's
like nothing other mm-hmm what if your
friend died you're just making people
laugh because your friend died mmm
you're gonna be an all come depends on
the friend you seem to be fixated on
some of our friends dying yeah when's
your next UCB show yeah she's a really
good judge of character yeah I mean you
can you can eventually maybe I mean it's
possible you know I mean sometimes
people can find humor and very dark
stuff and sometimes people need to hear
that to get through it like when a comic
passes away right they'll do a big
memorial for them at a big comedy club
where all the comics come and they try
to remember our friend who's passed away
those are honestly the best comedy shows
I've ever been to because they're so
real but you know try not you know yeah
I you don't need to talk about
everything that happens in your life
just the couple just when your friends
die yeah I said any other questions
okay what happens when your friends die
[Laughter]
how does comedy make me happy that's a
good question I think that we all love
to make people laugh and I think that
brings us a lot of happiness seeing
people that earn all different kinds of
moods sometimes people go to comedy
clubs - laughs to have a good time
sometimes they need to laugh and I think
you know being able to make people laugh
makes makes me happy I don't want to I
don't know about Chad
well for example didn't want chunk
everybody have a good I'm at the
Pittsburgh improv this weekend dates out
the gates and when you do the comedy
clubs you know what you get free food
free drinks in a hotel room that's fun
right that's a good question nobody
knows it's almost like a firing line
isn't it it's kind of weird that is
interesting cause it is interesting
probably because stand-up comedy started
in weird places and they try to keep it
turret I don't know if somebody put up a
wall and everybody just ran with it
it is weird right every single one yeah
I don't know man that's a very good
question that's yeah that's a different
present wait stand-up comedy just where
you like stand no I us I'm really out of
shape I sit a lot I sit a whole long
it's like Spalding Gray yeah yeah yeah
yeah oh no man I don't know why they
call it stand-up they do call it
stand-up and some people sit why they do
it some people stand some people do
props
it'll Cosby sat okay
Jats yeah Late Late Late a lot - have
you gone and watch stand-up before yeah
yeah and watch it on television
mm-hmm I'm saying cuz you noticed the
brick walls you must have seen some some
standing sometimes I'll watch some sort
of comedy but sometimes I can't watch it
because you know sometimes it's not nice
sometimes it is definitely not nice
welcome to the real world you know
what's funny you'll have a Netflix
special before Sam triply yeah I totally
think so
you should try stand-up for this
presentation people names I don't even
know who these people are
yeah you don't have to don't worry about
it yeah you're the you have any jokes
have you ever told the joke have you
ever told the joke sometimes when you
tell a joke to to many people it's like
you can't tell them but them that joke
anymore cuz then it just gets old yeah I
know
Arielle you got to write new material
most of my jokes are about Ronald Reagan
yeah once again I do not even have a
clue who that is okay you ain't missing
much he's the president it was the
president of United States ah any other
questions feel like we've really soured
you on stand-up comedy I feel I'm
worried about all my friends dying I
feel like I'm nice I know you're so
young you're like dad dad don't fight oh
I like that hitting the notes how's it
inspired me Stan of cotton well you know
um you just want to be as good as you
can so you work harder when you work
harder you get better results and you
know it's a wonderful time for comedy
man it's a wonderful wonderful time to
be a comedian plus also being able to
work with so many funny people whose
bars your - yeah
and you know when you're broken like us
and we are broken
okay it's one of the few gigs you could
actually do I always say stand-up
comedy's how much money can you make off
your mental illness and some of us are
sicker than others some of us are richer
than others so it's a wonderful place
for the misfit toys what exactly welcome
to punch-drunk doing something is there
anything you'd like to do if you have a
hobby or anything
what's Sorna what's your favorite thing
to do
I don't know okay that's that's a lot
pressure for you to know you have a lot
of time man yeah 46 I'm just finding
this out I'm a little weird I don't know
either we don't trust us you literally
went to the two people that flame throw
their life so yeah and I'm not done
flame throwing it yeah we got some more
to go so thank you for coming on I hope
that helped if you want me to email you
my responses I can do that too
he wants to do this yeah I do
you should do some standup anything you
want to plug yeah just like you got a
appearances coming up you well you know
you're pretty smart I can tell you're
very smart person you're ended up on
them when they're teasing yeah I
understand what they're doing yeah you
should start doing comedy in classroom I
would love that
I would yeah get heckled just our
flame-throwing everybody put her up a
chaos on Tuesday you want five minutes
man you could do it yeah that sounds
like every studio Jack in Hollywood I
mean people are probably gonna be asking
you what are those people's names who
are they then it's kind of gonna get
annoying
trust me it's really annoying with
people you're like what does that mean
am i doing an interview are you
investigating a murder what is going on
here
with all these questions man I just
trying to pull you're good you're very
smart oh yeah you could do it you're
gonna kill this on this um thank you for
coming on our show we really appreciate
it and good luck with your project good
luck Sam tripley comm bookmark that on
your your iPad
[Applause]
you're great you're a regular Barbara
Walters
she's a Connie Chung of Chile
yeah that was fun right I mean this
girl's just girl I was like a
frost/nixon debate yeah that was really
weird dude I was like are you crying I
thought it was serious I thought he was
joking he's like ham but a third grader
comes in here and interviews like you're
bothering to make her ask questions was
like we were bothering her I know so
what do you want to ask go [ __ ] yourself
I know there was like nothing even
written on it yeah he's my questions and
it was just a question mark so comedy
right whose idea was that I have no clue
I mean I thought it would
yeah one is an audio guy over at soap
box I assumed the comedian it's kind of
smart he's like just come to work with
me will bother everyone that comes in
everybody here is relatively nice when I
relatively I'm really talking about
Aaron I was like I don't know anyone
that's mean I'm just I'm actually really
glad my dog didn't bite her on air that
why you were saying his children just
Joe that's good he wants to hurt kids
he's uh he's uh heard not heard it's
Aaron that wants to hurt to kiss was my
mic on okay Aaron's turn the mic off on
me a lot before I'm like you guys so
much it's the best we just kind of point
to him like kill it kill it kill her mic
kill the mic kill kill kill the mic you
try so hard not to swear I know try so
hard not to give them any the negative
of the world - yeah wouldn't be great to
go back and have that innocence again
that's just like Earth
our heads are filled with all this
garbage like we could just be young and
yeah I miss that just play times like
what I had no innocence at that age yeah
did you start drinking at each Tebow's
well before that I was starting fist
fighting men at [ __ ] 85 the mystery
was over all right let's go back to
whatever we were taught what were we
talking about what is this for though oh
yeah Johnny win tonight you leave
tonight Johnny I'm gonna find somebody
though are you ever coming back
Johnny probably not are you moving back
to Carolina yeah he wants to go back
back in the morning and [ __ ] make
love to women who are straight but dress
like lesbians who doesn't I don't know I
guess not
that was a crazy [ __ ] game last night
did dude just I mean that's what the NFL
wants that's exactly what the NFL wants
yes
Bam Bam if that's a preview for this
Super Bowl there then it feels just
gonna beat off that's exactly how they
would want people to go if you put
thousand to a thousand if you put the
Saints out there would be the exact you
know I mean that's who's either good I
mean the Patriots could beat the Chiefs
for sure yeah dad and then the the
Chargers to beat the Chiefs Steelers
come you know this for there's like
literally four to five teams in the NFC
in the AFC that's that could make it you
know it should be Rams and should or
Saints ask me what hell the NFC
Championship game if that's what it is
Rams Saints probably in New Orleans
that's gonna be just like last night bro
that's me a thousand to a thousand and
double overtime
yeah thousand to a thousand touchdown
touch them to those three defensive
touchdowns in that game and the homes
through six [ __ ] touchdowns first
team ever in history of NFL to score 50
and lose are the Chiefs pretenders or
they were the real deal the real deal I
mean the real deal but just [ __ ] sore
the Rams so the Saints who are the real
deal teams
those three for sure dude how the Bears
are pretty legit defense is no joke
Raiders two and eight I'm so pissed
rated John Niners yeah exactly
and now the Falcons are done no now I'm
pulling the ripcord - it's like I don't
want to win on Thursday why did you have
to win why did you have to win yeah why
Zelly
it's a little italy meaningless it was
one win you went from the first pick to
the third pick and one win you know it's
so funny is that we talked about this on
the show but Raiders traded Mack to
Bears instead of the Niners because they
thought the Bears we're gonna have a
Boris record and a higher traffic and
now the Niners have the number-one pick
right now yeah it's crazy
and the Bears defense is legitimate yeah
I mean they're old-school they're look
yeah really is that [ __ ] throwback to
the Bears they're good man true Bruce
he's doing pretty decent bad right I
mean he doesn't have these like mahomes
dazzling numbers why he manages the ball
well he doesn't turn it over to two
months I know he had won this game but
he Inez fleet-footed as they say he can
move the pocket around he can you know
turn on other league in what efficiency
QPR yeah boy I drew breezes when all is
said and done Drew Brees will own every
record yeah he'll pass Manning he'll
pass Brady you know Harv
all of them everybody he's clearly gonna
break every I mean every single record
he's five foot five yeah and he's got
that [ __ ] Hershey bar on his face you
ever seen that thing whatever it is yeah
they always shoot him from this side I
think he's like been having it
surgically removed throughout the years
lasering holy mole so you can't even
really totally see it there but if you
look back in the day he almost look like
a black guy was so big I never noticed
that that's rude did his mom go crazy
and she was like using his name to run
for office and he told her she couldn't
that's when who's that Purdue just get
that off you could cut that out just
yeah thing dude that's his thing that's
like his unibrow yeah I mean now yeah
but that's when he was [ __ ] way back
in the day does he get chicks with that
I'm sure his wife Elle Decor nope show
his kids very cute see his wife
I'm sure she's this yeah what if that's
her thing like she's into that but
that's just one of his women his wife
she's pretty cute you know he's got
about eight or nine side numbers they
all do dude I mean pay manning was
banging somebody on the side
was he yeah he's got a Glock mark yeah
what he got call it no he didn't getting
[ __ ] is a man Manning's a god do you
think Peyton Manning was on HGH yeah
they all were yeah yeah the hour do you
think Laura all the Mannings were all
the Mannings even his mom was a she
agent really yeah see her cookies
they're [ __ ] insane by Eli [ __ ] do
enough didn't do enough
HGH then I didn't do [ __ ] for him time
to go
Eli it's been a nice run alright totally
agree isn't there another Manning
brother somewhere yeah Cooper yeah he
didn't make it
yeah he was supposedly the best out of
all of them yeah he what he wanted to be
a wide receiver nobody got injured like
blew his knee out and then never got it
took HGH and now he's just a
professional shopper that's the easier
softer way yeah he looks like the worst
Manning to him yeah yep yeah they all
have that [ __ ] American Psycho right
it's like we just wanna make the
neighborhood safe for the children and
then he [ __ ] chicks with nice to their
throats
Cooper you want to do a Papa John's
commercial
yeah they all look alike they all look
like they'd just been inbred [ __ ]
yeah that's genetics for you my mom
didn't do [ __ ] three boys all of them
quarterbacks in the NFL no rocks ever
one yeah who's better
I meant a dad and two brother who'd win
in a fight the triply brothers are the
Manning brothers do you have two
brothers no I've known me my brother
versus those three guys I mean can we
bring well I don't Sam I know Sam and I
know trips beador Ian quite well I don't
think they're gonna bode very well three
NFL quarterbacks the problem with them
is they're all been injured a thousand
times like I might have a little on Plus
you know karate kind of kind of kind of
I don't know I think I've gone with them
the professional athlete brothers do you
think Eli Isaiah is a to get Famer yeah
yeah I do to people like talking's not
gonna go home
he's a Manning anyone got big numbers he
was a quarterback for the Giants forever
won two Super Bowls his numbers you know
speak for himself relatively I think
he's either the only or the last one to
be the quarterback that play for a team
at 100 games and lost 100 games dude
he's won he's 111 no he's not 100 100
but he's won more than 100 games ba yeah
yeah let's go to the phones Jason what
are you doing it's in my head what's
that oh yeah what is it
I mean really in the last [ __ ] five
years all you've really been hearing is
people bitching about Eli yeah forever
everybody talked about how good he was
but the last like half a decade back
they shouldn't have sometimes people try
to get those records of like hey this
guy's got 219 consecutive starts or
whatever you're losing Pullum yeah I
don't give a [ __ ] about that record yeah
I mean you gotta look at the Giants they
got a wonderful Y receiving a wonderful
running back bro that kids special yeah
they're gonna they're gonna build around
him twice yeah
dude do you think anybody could get
Matthew Stafford if they threw enough
ones I just dumped them off my fantasy
team if you want him I know thanks for
that trade Johnny I don't know if I can
[ __ ] she's a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
he's the words he manipulated you he was
doing it the other day
yeah don't ever don't make trades with
Johnny I learned a lesson yeah valuable
I thought you didn't even check it or
anything I do oh yeah I'm just not on it
like he is I don't care
why didn't you change your team I just
forget to hit submit like I'm
downloading something I'll go back and I
forget yeah it's hard that's great I
changed my lineup I just didn't hit
submit it should change submit it
anyways for you I hate the ESPN Fantasy
app you hate ESPN in general I do i do
hate ESPN and gentle but the yahoo one's
way better yeah i think it's easier to
navigate through it never has problems
loading [ __ ] ESPN's fantasy app that's
what I say their fantasy apps too
political for me yeah I mean [ __ ] I feel
like Stafford other than when he had
Megatron has really never had help
they haven't had a good running back in
his
higher career in Detroit defense ever
ever and other than that he said one I
mean I guess I guess uh Tate Tate was
good was here but they just raided him
which was weird I felt they pulled it
early huh here's the thing dude
if you ain't winning it you should be
[ __ ] tanking it and with Matthew
Stafford you're always gonna have a
couple wings and you're never gonna get
that yeah Roy Williams go bust Nate
brozen too old
tide is too young even [ __ ] gives a
[ __ ] how come one thy fall or nobody who
yeah for like to do two or three years
yeah it was pretty sick he went from the
Niners to the Lions why does every time
Detroit has a prolific scorer they
retire in their prime because it's
because they run the [ __ ] and tread off
the tires and just ride one player the
the organization is owned by people who
are batshit crazy and don't know how to
run a football team it's like every
sport the owners dictate the the
competency of your franchises so if you
it's like one of family's crazy the dads
crazy the family's crazy just the way it
is so the Lions have been owned by
people don't know what the [ __ ] they're
doing I mean look at this right here Sam
because so you go Johnny just looked up
best Detroit Lions running back first
one Barry Sanders next one Javeed best
that's quite a drop off yeah Kevin Jones
Michael Asher
Kevin Smith joint Bal member joyd Bell
yeah I mean all of these guys are just
like whatever
Jerome Harrison can you look up what um
what uh Tom Brady salary is please
yeah I ignored it it's [ __ ] up I had
it earlier but then I recorded a car
yeah Johnny was on it and you did Sam
just ignored it I wonder if we're going
to psychologically harm that child and
you can make a bet on that at bat DSi
that D aside for all your betting needs
go to our friends Betty side comm use
the promo code punch 25 and guess what
guess what you get $25 bank cat okay and
then on top of that they'll match
anything you deposit and it's time to
bet right
there's it's the NFL playoffs around the
corner last night if you took the over
like 70% of the people that did they
beat it by 40 the highest over-under in
the history of the NFL was 64 last night
and they beat it by 40 some casinos are
reporting losses under the millions yeah
on the over-under last they'll be fine
they'll be fine like when the vet when
the the Vegas Golden Knights made it to
the to the Stanley Cup you if they would
have won that did they say they would
have bankrupt Vegas that's how I knew
they had no chance of winning
well none none but you know you could
have bet on it you could have gone back
to your side use promo code punch 25 and
basically anything you deposit the match
up it's very money and guess what throw
up a three-team parlay on the [ __ ] on
Thanksgiving games this week
you got three games on Thursday you get
the Lions and the Bears got the Cowboys
and Redskins you got Falcon Saints throw
your free 25 bucks on a little parlay
there and have yourself a Happy
Thanksgiving
thanks to our good friends at bet DSi
get the app place all the bets that you
want they got prop bets big odd
everything you can bet on politics there
ah Alex White is that his name the
quarterback who's the quarterback for
the Washington Redskins miss okay Alex
Smith [ __ ] could be career ender Anne
yeah for sure
22 million is the answer to your
question for Brady I know how much is
everybody else making is he making the
most of all the quarterbacks oh no no
no that's he's it's gonna be Aaron
Rodgers and Matt Ryan and
what's-his-name in Detroit
Stafford what did the center my god II
like 210 million less is a good a good
ah [ __ ] cut and pay well
he's 26 22 tie-rod he's 21 dude I'm
telling you man
he takes less money and like you're like
okay where they spend this [ __ ] money
but it's all like contractual like every
one of these guys ahead of Drew Brees
all of their contracts came up in the
last year and each one became high-spade
highest-paid highest-paid now you're
gonna kill that that's got Johnny
pull-up Sam tripley's income I don't
think that would be on there it's always
funny everybody just come up like who
did I'd see on Instagram that was it
might have been like favor Minh or
somebody it was said like one point nine
million dollars and favor ins like I
don't know I gotta get a new accountant
I don't know where all this money's at
yeah it just makes up numbers yeah it
makes up numbers who he thinks that all
the comedian's getting paid the most out
of every comedian out there right now
he's probably you think what do you mean
like it's are insane I mean some forbes
list last year wasn't he I mean Seinfeld
gets like a million bucks I said or
something right yeah sure from that that
Netflix deal he made
Sebastian stopped these at number 10 15
million yeah he's on that list so that's
am in Jesus Christ Amy sure made 37
million dollars that's just movies
though she's like not doing any stand-up
stuff lately she's pregnant
oh geez yeah
who smoked one into her she married a
chef emeritus chef of course she did
Kevin Brown was like she should have
married an athletic trainer yeah I think
he's hilarious oh just like shits on
everybody he doesn't care about anything
there's mark Normand to the left hey
fatty
somebody somebody said her husband's a
celebrity dick Ryder well I'm glad she
brushed her hair for her wedding she
doesn't usually look presentable it was
probably not wearing a [ __ ] orange
jumpsuit good for her do it I marry her
to drop of hat I marry him I marry any
of you right now let's all get married
right now did she tell everyone to vote
at her when I marry Sam that drop the
Hat I marry Sam did she make you say me
about not doing commercials during a
Super Bowl which everybody's like
nobody's asking you to do [ __ ]
commercials that's super bowl that
Hinchcliffe tweet was great I mean dude
it's just like I mean like I have
nothing against her man I just think she
plays [ __ ] all wrong but then again I'm
not at that level so I wouldn't know but
she does this kind of trainwreck kind of
publicity things where she like she
trainwreck it's a movie of hers yeah I
mean like she does this whole thing
where she's like like when she tells
everybody that mm people are 200 people
walked out of my show in Tampa fact went
off on Trump and it's just like why are
you telling everybody this like what are
you doing I know from an inside source
exclusive that Baker Mayfield gay know
all the time so you could break all of
it you know who told him Baker Mayfield
was gay his mouth his [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] up man no amy has a somebody in
her camp that contacts the paparazzi
they all do that yeah so she's
constantly in the news cycle constantly
oh yeah that didn't surprise me oh I
just like I just you got to go away once
in a while man yeah people get tired of
hearing you yeah like you would away
after premium blend yeah for like
[ __ ] decades real rude dude as real
rude I love zoom ox lat proud laughter
of himself he has one laugh right it's
like is something funny and he has
another laugh when he's like I just did
I made a funny
I got him you got roast battle I just
won I'm Frank Castillo how come you
didn't do how come you haven't done the
roast bale out here yeah I was going to
but I was just like I don't want to I
think it's played out man oh all right I
write roast jokes for people all the
time I like doing that but I don't know
if I want to do it yeah so yeah it's it
has become I mean the live one not that
not that television version one but the
one at the comedy story it has become
like a lot of I don't know who any of
those people are yeah it's a lot of like
very new comics there yeah it really is
mm-hmm yeah it definitely is like I
wrote for the Bruce Willis Rose for
Nicky I gave her a bunch of jokes I
think one made it to the air but
whatever nothing you just do stuff and
nothing happens yeah I did welcome yeah
we should told that girl that comedy
it's [ __ ] unforgiving that's one
right now um so what about funny things
listen listen look at the face of
[ __ ] reality look how about what a
funny low art Gaver
huh yeah it's an unforgiving okay
it breaks men we don't make fun of our
friends when they die we're the friends
that died let's recreate it I'm the girl
okay tell me what why do you like comedy
because I have a crippling drug and
alcohol problem
I'm stealing plays I can [ __ ]
function I do it for the free chicken
haha
this is unforgiving I get chicken
fingers it crushes my soul next question
how do you come up with jokes I [ __ ]
playing through my life I steal them I
steal them from funnier people than I I
say what's gonna hurt little girl's
feelings and I just shred them huh again
this I crushed nobody [ __ ] cares lady
people like you grow into be the soul
stomping women that I date yeah you end
up dating people hi I bet I know your
favorite Chris D'Elia isn't it hot Aaron
see [ __ ] Krista Leah isn't it that's
exactly what it is guys also look into
Ryan Sickler uh weird album just came
and we have two people coming on next
week mine's Ryan Sickler and Anthony
Kumi a okuu me oh yeah I do a show yeah
I told her I go hey the they go hating
come in tonight I think no no no dude
the next dude next week call me it's
great now why scrap fees over why they
quittin because they said that you broke
the internet I think they're just big
dude seven years a long time due popular
podcast that's very popular but I think
they just both want to do different
things how long you been doing
punch-drunk you guys respond that Oh
Jess and run there so you guys gonna
quit to where every shows our farewell
show yeah we're like we're like kiss for
the last 20 years we've been doing
farewell shells
our first show was our farewell show who
has that joke of like if somebody does a
farewell tour
I thought Dean tweets something about
like if someone doesn't farewell tour
and they come back you should get free
da yeah yeah you should get your money
back dude I went to the Rolling Stones
farewell tour in 91 yeah so who's the
gene Simmons and Paul Stanley out of you
and Tebow I'm the Ringo Starr oh yeah
I'm with a Bobby Brown of new addition
what's fight nanny she's [ __ ] she's
our Lady gaga [ __ ] who got on a show
how'd you meet her Lady Gaga how'd you
meet her Lady Gaga is very successful
yes yeah I wish I was that rich you're
the one you're the one that you're the
one that's gonna come out of this on top
you
are you're gonna secretly worship saying
kill us all off steal our personas and
be and do a movie well that's when we're
all on that island together always
discussed I kill everyone off who do you
like more out of Jason and Sam honestly
come on you know that's an easy answer
clearly clearly is this the first mini
famosos yeah I mean I don't know I don't
really care to see like a Rolling Stones
now no I don't I mean it's like tickets
are so expensive
yeah to go see him yeah I saw 98 degrees
last night for $25 we're at a [ __ ]
Burger King what [ __ ] Chuckie really
walk in with that story girl that's why
I was late you know you're late cuz you
had a long night of watching 98 degrees
just talk to the boss outside in a room
room-temperature [ __ ] and it was like
all Christmas songs you guys it's like
so as well oh my god did she make you
watch youtube videos I came home was
like Jeff
they reenacted the Grinch and like the
Alvin and the Chipmunks and it was so
embarrassing and I made him watch on
YouTube because it's like okay Johnny
I'll pull it up now I act like I'm
literally like I literally felt blood
flow into my dick when he told me this
I've gotta see I got like the chills but
I didn't know if it's like in a good way
or a bad way
oh I'm excited for this
[Applause]
and then we googled it they're all 45
and they're doing that
this is [ __ ] man Nick Lachey so looks
the same no he does Reef I love that
your wife wants you know it was so cheap
it was so worth it I would see it again
if I wasn't here recording Felipe I
probably would have been there as well
oh yeah you would have got everything
that makes me happy
they had some good some good songs if I
knew it was Christmas I'd done without
him go they played all their hits though
I'm sure you all one of them yeah how
many hits is 98° happy for really yeah
that looks like Aaron right there right
doesn't it look like Aaron like he
joined 90 degrees he looks like a
Manning the worst part was they have
like an original Christmas songs that
was the worst it's like justing frosty
yeah I just wanted to say ten what is
your ritual for 98° song I mean I didn't
I've never owned an album but there's my
friend was like do you want to go for
$25 I was like absolutely but I
recognized like four other songs and
what were they that the hardest thing
because oh that song that give me just
one night una noche I thought was
Enrique Iglesias it's like a Spanish
song we got to give the nick lachey he
banged Jessica Simpson our prime
unbelievable back in the day hottest I
met her in person
whoo and Dane Cook did that stupid movie
brought her the improv gorgeous gorgeous
sad I mean like I'm nothing against Dane
but that bad very well of course go to
the improv with you just fell off
where's she now I think she just had a
baby and like it's doing her mom know
she has the fashion line she's like very
successful you know who else did that
was awesome Milano oh yeah she she got
made up talking mint and her family's
very pregnant right now she's like huge
don't be mean to her I see a banger
pregnant
who is she's married to an ex-football
player who looks like Stan that's who
who's Eric Johnson that he's clearly
very successful if neither one of us
wikipedia he's a guitar player I mean
it's such a normal name
there's probably because Jillian Eric
John says I'll play him for somebody
would you play Oh Niners okay he's 39
but he looks like he's 84 yeah I'm in
heaven
Vernon Davis yeah him and Vern Vernon
Davis were there two titans nice nice
they look like every Scottsdale family
they absolutely absolutely look like
every Scottsdale family bro right
exactly right I don't want to one-up
your story but guess who I met over the
weekend 99° is a town does the name Cru
Jones ring a bell oh no [ __ ] yeah
doesn't ring a bell at all there's a
movie from the 80s that I wore out on
VHS called rad the BMX movie yeah the
bike rider the lead guy Cru Jones I
forgot his real name madam gave me his
phone number it was awesome BMX it was
awesome so is he gonna be on sit-down
with Chad sumac he'll do my podcast yeah
he'll probably be a roommate at this rad
rad was awesome you don't remember this
no no [ __ ] look at this oh yeah dope
dude it was all about BMX it's this guy
was a paper or a delivery boy he's
probably molested to get that role that
guy's been in everything
Talia Shire was his mom from rocky
Adrian that's it right here that's him
right there
I don't know with that guy that guy's
got like cross-eyed like he's blowing
nose I'm Bibi I think this was the he's
done a lot of stuff at look at his
eighties bad guys yeah classic eighties
bad guys so this is my prod ECOD before
the Karate Kid yeah you don't even know
what this guy's looking at he had a race
he'll track it was this big Bart tail
was is the look at this Lori Loughlin
from Full House was in it
Wow that is her you really really Ward
this out huh oh it was dude I was this
is the kind of thing the Zeeman and
these two [ __ ] non-stop watts in the
80s I was a BMX nerd I loved being but
you never rode BMX I did too and what
house good I grow out of it I notice BMX
that's very cool so what happens in this
they got it like win the race to say the
orphanage exactly right I'll guarantee
you that that's what it is
no he's just a local tomboy that went up
against the best and one that's a
feel-good story it's like Rocky yeah and
did this inspire you to do stand-up no
not at all
so you met him he's like yeah what was
he your post mate delivery guy yeah he's
just riding a BMX in a circle with a hat
for cash from a tries to what else was
the on was he on anything else now he's
been in a bunch of stuff he's a he's a
working actor he's been in Breaking Bad
he was in a he wasn't that hot drinking
rad raking rad yeah ug she brought that
up while we combined no Alan look he's a
bunch of [ __ ] he was born the 4th of
July how dare you
China Beach Family Ties whose own
[ __ ] family dies amazing stories you
do your pics too cuz I gotta getting the
basketball Oh block of the week yeah see
what we got here
I I'll tell you right now it's Saints
over the Falcons I didn't even need to
see that spread it could be 50 it's
gonna be Saints over the balcony your
your your defense gets hurt a lot like
last year the same thing right we
weren't too banged up last year this
year it's
we're completely [ __ ] so here go the
odds here Chargers [ __ ] up man you
know so many games were decided by Allah
three points or less this week really
was a but the NFL wants when it comes to
parody even that high-scoring game last
night look how big his [ __ ] arms are
Jesus Christ yeah let's see kid
Cincinnati Cleveland huh [ __ ] that game
what happened to the jacks I mean the
quarterback mortals yeah III don't see
him being around I don't see Eli being
around I don't see borders being around
Jackson I think Jackson wins it would
wins this we mean what happened that
defense just fell off I mean dude the
keeping bortles was just so a wrong move
dude I could see them go after Matthew
Stafford like he's what they need they
need an established quarterback Derek
Carr somebody somebody'll go somewhere
well you know they need a guy that can
throw the ball you know I can see moving
it's Flacco really yeah they got [ __ ]
Jackson sitting in behind him on the
dash red yeah who wants that from their
quarterback does anybody want Tyrod
Taylor from the Browns yeah I could see
him going somewhere yeah for sure
there's a lot of those guys dude if
you're not throwing the ball you're
[ __ ]
what do you know how many times he throw
I think it's 20 times it's something
it's good dude I'm feyza i don't think
he's a quarterback in the NFL i think i
think is but i don't think i don't think
that's what they need to be doing dude
if listen man if you don't have a guy
that doesn't have a rifle arm that is
accurate that's a lot of times for a
running back to run 27 Oh Bridgewater I
could see making a difference somewhere
yeah Bridgewater might be good
Brett Huntley I don't see him doing
anything simian can SMB Hodgeman counts
probably got a year or two left by
Bridgewater that'd be a good I can see
Bridgewater please no your pick is what
I'm going st. Omer the Falcons I don't
care if that spreads 914 is 13 maybe I'm
fine with that
Falcons gonna get [ __ ] butt [ __ ]
Cleveland vs Cincinnati the Battle of
i-71 watching paint dry that game I give
a [ __ ] we're 3 6 & 1 or somethin mmm
that's about right yeah
you guys had some decent I still know
what did it I you guys just need a
competent coax look at that dude that's
a good season for you oh it's a great
season coming off on Owen 16 season
that's a who do you guys beat last week
[ __ ] Falco what was bye week no you
beat the Rockets yeah oh yeah you beat
the [ __ ] out of [ __ ] there are
[ __ ]
really Falcons dude yep and that was the
end that's where the season ended for
the Falcons and then lost to Dallas
again and now I don't just pull the
ripcord
well those were called a wrap no need to
be 500 no need to be 500 I don't know
why the Oakland Raiders one that [ __ ]
game just like do we want bow saw 176
yards Nick Chubb that guy not to throw
you guys off track but isn't it weird
like everyone's like making a big
outrage Louie's going on stage but
Michael Vick used to kill [ __ ] dogs
just kill them and nobody cares well you
can't say anything because he's black is
that what it is
of course well and he also went to jail
for two years and serves lots of hundred
million dollars yeah started Louis
though they say I think that's kind of
maybe what I'm saying okay but no one if
you would have paid he didn't pay for
anything that he did yeah you know I
mean like when it when when push comes
to shove you talk about Vick you could
only be like well
learned his lesson and he did pay his
debt to society I think everybody's
saying the Louie didn't he just got to
do whatever he wanted but he still lost
a lot of money he lost a lot she lost TV
shows he lost the movie they took his
specials off Netflix the movie that was
in the can isn't even gonna be released
was already in the can because there's a
lot of weird sexual [ __ ] with it yeah
yeah yeah it's gonna be interesting
comeback man I mean II will for sure
dude I love her but we always knew louis
ck's comeback would be easy it hasn't
been easy
it hasn't at all no it's it's a
nightmare
Pete how about this how about these two
chicks get the pic somebody has to jerk
off in front of them I think that's fair
I think that's even steven yeah that he
has to watch somebody just off yeah I'll
do it did you tweet that Jason turn it
often from Lucy Kane yeah even steven I
mean hey I don't know we've said it on
this before but I just don't see the big
[ __ ] what they do what I just don't
see the big hoopla over all of it
I mean there's bigger fish to fry then
you know he got lumped in with all these
[ __ ] crazy people dude you know it
doesn't matter if you're a rapist a
pedophile it's like you're just lumped
into it it's true
yeah it's like there's no like what are
you jerking off um do you think we
should be more understanding of
pedophiles that's what I'm saying like
come on comes from slack
yeah that's I mean let's give him a
break no I'm just saying like Bill Cosby
that like Louise Bill Cosby now he's
Harvey Weinstein it's yeah it's like the
problem yeah he's getting clumped in
with these guys even Aziz who I think
it's a shitty comedian but it's a shitty
person in a shitty person but they throw
him in with like pedophiles and [ __ ]
yeah bad date I mean that's just that's
the whole problem look at this dude like
why are you criticizing Sarah Silverman
she said she liked it when he beat off
in front of her what is the problem here
you can't make jokes about anything
anymore just like this little wasn't
named Susie the little girl they
interviewed us there's only one thing
that's funny when your friend
die that's it I agree
that was crazy that was funny that ya
even understand without no coming from
so it's like when your friends die it's
like you just make fun of that yeah
we're like of course yeah dude that's my
best stuff what we got here is ex
accused him of an attack that could have
meant life in prison yeah you just say
stuff and you're guilty
yeah that's why women just in this town
believe all women they all they all
eternalized it and made it about what
they went through yeah and like every
one of these chicks you ask them like
especially communities oh what's the
problem it's problem it's always an open
mic er it's always an open mic er try to
get some ass for stage time and now we
all have to pay the price for the rest
of our [ __ ] life
cuz an open mic er that guy's an [ __ ]
yeah he's an [ __ ] to everybody right
like where are where do you go where you
don't have guys hitting on you nowhere
yeah it's like everywhere you go you're
gonna have guys hitting on you I get hit
on by guys all the time yeah if you look
that way too well I only pretty much I'm
gonna hang out in gay bars and I don't
wear pants a lot but still can I have
some [ __ ] respect
sure I'm naked in a gay bar spent
overspreading my ass open that might be
making it too easy though my mom passed
that it was like he's desperate maybe
maybe I do a joke in my act I go the me
tube movements the ice bucket challenge
of sexual assault it's pretty good I
guess I could see that dad did you uh
did you take a tweet your tweet Chad
likes to do that
Chad likes to retweet his own tweets
sometimes are really good yeah I thought
you liked that move did you ever take
the [ __ ] bucket challenge
what's the [ __ ] bucket Jeff it's like 12
dudes come in a bucket and then you pour
it over all of us I did to fight cancer
I nominate Chad sumac
of course we're gonna seize would love
to come bucket challenge do you think
Neal Brennan would have directed that
gay porn yeah he's supposed to do that
but then we mind up doing it live at the
show instead oh this right here look at
my big-time promotion for Sycamore yeah
Lee give that dude look at that
did you retweet that one I didn't
retweet that one
I haven't retweeted look I promoted
punch from it's very nice of you
yeah but it's cuz you were on it exactly
alright that's enough
yeah Chad [ __ ] enough can we talk
some basketball goddamn Oh criminy Chad
Chad will we call this off zeroes for
Zions is that what you're going for is
that what they're doing zeroes for Zion
from Duke yeah for Cleveland that whole
thing's won it first that all teams one
and done though the whole team's all
awesome I said freshmen right say they
say four years they're gonna go four
years there is no way education is
important I don't think anybody in
college basketball from now on will ever
play four years of college basketball
anymore no I mean it's actually seen as
a bad thing yeah I can see that I'm
wasting money on those lists huh Joel
nope Rudy got nope
no white people no [ __ ] how racist is
that oh by the way did you guys hear
that the WNBA sing about going on strike
when they've lost like 12 million
dollars
the league's lost twelve million dollars
strike for what they want more money
yeah what's the average salary for the
WNBA like what's considered bass I think
you know anyone know I don't I say
thirty grand
yeah I think it's around like fifty I
would be $165,000 as a female are you
offended by this 71 they never
and they're like we should be making
that kind of money - no no you shouldn't
you do not generate that kind of
business
they literally shoot camera wise down on
the court so you can't see how empty the
stadium's are so the arena's 171 does
dude you are the third biggest
basketball professional basketball
league in the United States
after the big three the big three is
bigger than the WNBA there's more people
go into those games than go to others
less games - in the big three you mean
oh I see what you're saying you time off
not college now including college yeah
because I think women's college
basketball is more popular than the WNBA
yeah I think so too
I think you're right I mean cuz that
they'll they'll sell out stadiums I mean
dude that's a game yeah that's not like
before the game nope oh my god there's
40 in a big stadium there's more people
on the court and then there are in the
stands
dude they got a lower the [ __ ] in the
problem yeah lower the risk inside sport
during the summer nobody wants to go
inside okay
another thing is they can't move it to
the wintertime because the the premier
women's basketball league is in Russia
during that time what is it the WNBA
Finals are during a weird time - right
yeah yeah it's always like the problem
with the WNBA is compared to the NBA and
you just can't compare them can you name
should lower the rhibs can you knit and
you look basketballs you all-time
favorite sport can you name five WNBA
players I cannot I can't do one I could
sue Byrne I just remember Rebecca Lobo
because she was like the first one and
what's-her-name from the Lakers not on
average we lost over ten mil every year
we've operated it is literally a loss
leader it's a tax write-off and and now
they want more money it's just not gonna
happen we say that Adam silver
yeah I'm silver says well he's a [ __ ]
Jew whoa controversy
chair called in dropped em bombs
remember that oh yeah oh my god
chaos ensued I love how that was up
voted 96% of time you know people are
just like yeah dude it's just that is
that is social justice warriors right
there equal effort they think equal
effort equals equal results and that's
just not what happens what if the strike
just leads to no more so you and B it
really blows up what a shame for them
though we didn't well then they'll all
go to Russia and make a shitload of
money yeah they all go play in Russia
you're listening one of your listeners
should mail in WNBA jerseys for you guys
to work I want us to do a fantasy WNBA
league there's not gonna fancy WNBA
there's not there's gotta be there's not
I guarantee you there that would be fun
hell no no that would not but I think I
I don't know how the NBA would miss out
on that opportunity WM be fancy see
where it is Fuson start a fantasy league
holy [ __ ]
Oh Oh Daly that's a that's a FanDuel one
does he gotta be white girl down there
she's literally the greatest female
basketball player of all time like she
is dominated what certain anything she's
ever done nope the girl on the bottom
she's like she won four championships in
a row at UConn she just won her first WH
she's just a next level player
punch-drunk sports the official home of
the WNBA I have to talk w Brett yeah
Breanna Stewart she's like next level
why didn't you know her name because I
don't follow
but you knew more about her than you
know about Sue Bird actually I don't
yeah I don't I know there was one hot
Australian who got naked in a [ __ ] in
a naked in like an Australian magazine
people went nuts of course you know that
right I mean it's just high there are a
couple hot ones like the last couple of
drafts have been [ __ ] hot she's cute
is it true only for women in the WNBA
like men yeah I mean it's like some
crazy number they basically make they
basically make who's the old comic money
WME hey there Road comics yeah they make
road comics like the NBA players of the
Joe Rogan's and the WNBA players all the
rest of the road comic yeah you know
it's just we go can we get just gonna
kid is that that chick that was went to
Notre Dame yeah Scott she's hot yeah
she's pretty attractive yeah I mean did
a good audio but this is a league for
your mother man she likes this like to
just sit back throw a little hot sauce
on some vagina eat some box and watch
some women play oh it was like who's
this [ __ ] put those sheep okay
you were just randomly looking up stuff
yeah blinks just shelling chef who
helicopter I'm excited for Thanksgiving
why are you excited for Thanksgiving
three great games
we can't talk any basketball we are
early no we're talking women's
basketball that's not what did you want
to say about NBA oh just go to the
rankings to go to the standings please
let's take a look at this I was mocked I
was mocked by Neal Brennan mocked for
saying that the Clippers we're gonna be
good
get him on the phone what's that what
are we tied for number 11 on shout out
to Richard at the comedy a magic club
saying they're the team to root for our
Raptors are still rolling huh yeah I
mean dude they got a better player quite
Leonard is as good as anybody in the
league he's Kevin Durant LeBron James
level good are they better without Blake
Griffin go who the Clippers yes
obviously yeah had to get rid of him
yeah because he's to Hollywood and yet
contracts just too big
the Lakers being nine and seven me too I
mean dude we are killing it I told
everybody Detroit was gonna be way
better this year because Blake Griffin
is a franchise player what's their
record they're eight and six but they
were [ __ ] last year you guys are late
though - yeah I mean like like pretty
much at the trade deadline I'm trying to
act like he's not grateful he's an
awesome player he's a franchise level
player he just need to get out of here
because he's doing all those Neal
Brennan sketch shells Neal Brennan
killed Lob City okay he roomed it have
him [ __ ] Chris Paul do sketch comedy
get the [ __ ] out leave alone write that
one you you always hear that he's like a
jerk yeah nobody likes him yeah it seems
like nobody likes Chris Paul yeah nobody
likes him everywhere he goes it's too
much power he has too much saying
everything head of the Players
Association you know he got Doc Rivers
and that as a coach but then Doc Rivers
ended up coming the the GM and that
ruined that team right and then they uh
and now he got Carmelo Anthony on the
Rockets and uh and they Flint and now
that team sucks I mean it's just just
Chris Paul is too much Power Man too
much power he's dirty
I don't mind dirty I like dirty players
yeah I prefer dirty I wish everybody was
dirty dude I just saw if speaking of
Michael Rapaport who's gonna be on was
he in the movie rad no but he just did a
interview with Charles Oakley and
Scottie Pippen and Scottie Pippen and
Charles Oakley basically said Isaiah
Thomas is a [ __ ] they have zero respect
from it was the greatest they [ __ ]
hated Isaiah everybody hated Isaiah
Isaiah was gay you think yeah for sure
he's got gay face Isaiah Thomas has gay
face yeah well I don't you would know
yeah I do I have a Grilli good gaydar
and I've been in some weird situations
so it's like [ __ ] yeah so gay face
everyone the Knicks organization should
hate
everybody to nix everybody up the next
what other teams a flame throw this the
CBA flame throwback this Raptors sirs
Pacers you know Joe Dumars ruined the
ruin the Detroit Pistons he made him he
got him a champion about lucky draw he
got that lucky trade for Rasheed Wallace
after that that was a great dance where
horrible she'd they draft and Wallace
[ __ ] the mayor cornrow guy what was
the cornrow guy with the face mask oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah Hamilton so dude
what about the I told everybody without
Steph Curry the Warriors are the OKC
Thunder Steph Curry makes that team go
he said next level god of course and now
he hasn't been there and they're just
starting to fight this could be the end
who's coming out of the West yeah behind
the Clippers ones a lot when is that
team I'd take that yeah yeah yeah
that's almost a fourth it's almost a
fourth that's a lot okay all right
zip your piehole I'm just telling you
this team is deep at Sam Tripoli on
Twitter if you were to predict the
finals right now what would it be today
before I mean it looks like I mean out
of a I'll be uh what we have to see how
Jimmy Butler blends with that 76ers team
because they have the most talent mm-hmm
the West I mean I ve they have that by
far the most talent through trial
Raptors are good to do they like they I
mean Kwai Leonard is a next level player
the Milwaukee Bucks are great there I
just don't think they have on tap for
the just they're missing a third
all-star they don't have enough talent
to win a chant out to win the playoffs I
mean dude just playing like [ __ ] huh
well he came off that horrible injury
yeah he's probably this that was a real
bad injury those are did you see when we
were terminals the Joe Theismann of the
NBA and I was I was going to say did you
see the ball
Oh Alex Smith injury yes I was a nasty
one no I'm just talking about nasty
injuries yeah I was nasty dude that was
nasty
his Gordon Hayward's wasn't like you
look in his [ __ ] foots like pretty
much twisted off yeah man I mean like
he's got some good games he's got
getting to the flow he's gonna be fine
dude he's a great player I think you
will too
he just got get his legs back man it's
finished he'll be on the Hornets before
you know it I think he's too young to to
be you know if he was older he's [ __ ]
fine dude
the team's fine if I if I was the Lakers
I would trade for John Wall right now
trade for John Wall who D trade
Lonzo ball for John Wall yeah why would
they do that because the Lakers not the
Lakers why would because this the
Washington Wizards are imploding fight
man you think he thought he looks like
my ex-boyfriend from high school and all
my friends always show me him so yes he
looks like me nobody else you've ever
banged in your life everybody else it's
just weird-looking that you've had sex
with just great you think Jeff's a
supermodel
Genet super freak he's a wonderful guy
guy I mean dude is he's a good guy he's
a comedian that we all look weird I
think Jeff's more handsome than this man
okay I like that that's nice
so do I I mean Nick Diaz miss Diaz Jason
Tebow I mean come on it's like the list
of unfuckable man come on the he went to
my uncle's funeral he did Gordon Hayward
congratulations my uncle wasn't even
dead he wasn't even dead it was a big
joke on him he's dead now though thank
God
nick swardson has that funny joke about
he he wants a like hire John Stamos to
come to his funeral just so people are
like is that John Stamos that guys
Angeles no Stamos he's 78 years old and
hasn't dude it looks exactly the same
yeah like jessimae Peluso has a big
[ __ ] she's in love with him
is in love with him I mean I'm the most
girls have been throughout that his run
yeah I mean he was ingesting the rippers
was he in was he in rat there we go yes
he and rad no but Lori Loughlin was from
full house how about that connection
connections you got it yes that's rude
that's rude ah
LeBron ji mean the Lakers aren't gonna
do jack [ __ ] they play the Cavs tomorrow
yeah
okay there make it such a big deal about
that running those [ __ ] they did an
entire campaign commercials for the
[ __ ] boring game of too shitty teams
yeah where's that game at in Cleveland
that's the only [ __ ] interesting part
yeah is hearing him get booed for
[ __ ] every time are they gonna boo I
don't I would personally I want because
it's just like he said he was never
gonna leave again he lied he's lawyer
he's an opportunist
he's full of [ __ ] dude tell me the
conspiracy you told me about LeBron
going to the Cavs why why okay let me
get comfortable cuz he has a firm or no
no he has an agency what's his agency
called clutch sports and at the time it
was just him and I think Eric Bledsoe so
clutch porch is based out of Cleveland
so he came back next he know who's on
clutch sports attrition Thompson you got
JR Smith got him all max contracts right
and they're building the roster and he
news they got that thing up and running
he's like okay this is good to go now I
go to LA we get the production going yes
what he's a [ __ ] businessman he
yanked his kids out of school he doesn't
give a [ __ ] he's a narcissist and a
sociopath I didn't mean to go down that
road he's a terrible father terrible
father well I already beats his kids
with dildos
in the butt in the butt mark my words
LeBron James rapes his children with
dildos my punch on sports.com nobody put
his you know two weeks will be honest
abyss decides up in two weeks he's a
complete he wants to be a mogul he
doesn't give a [ __ ] and he jumped on
that whole good Cleveland good faith
like we are Cleveland Cleveland or
nowhere he doesn't give a [ __ ]
more finals in a row dude I know you
know it's fine I think he I I've always
been a little you're in LA right now why
aren't you in Cleveland I'll be flying
out tonight red-eye I thought I've
always been a fan of his I I don't know
why people get their balls busted for
doing like what's in their best interest
financially or in their family's best
interest the guys got show on Showtime
and HBO
that's unheard of yeah it's unheard of
and it's shitty shows they're not good
they're so bad they're so bad the
barbershop thing horrible they're
drinking wine they don't do that
barbershops i watch the first one is it
although they're all bad all garbage
it's all yeah i'll watch the first one i
was kinda like i get this i see how this
ago but it wasn't anything to be like a
show like that as like i would watch it
depending on who the guest is you I
wouldn't watch every single episode
right you know there's a Joey watch none
of them yeah you haven't watched you
haven't seen it no I just have no
interest yeah no I don't care about any
of that stuff first one that's alright I
mean LeBron James has been [ __ ] filthy
what's his other show forever oh I don't
know what survivors remorse that's on go
on like I forget what is show on a h/h
that's the HBO the the barbershop any
got the network TV show the wall with
Chris Hardwick yeah okay bring that back
I don't know and then they're in
production of Space Jam to which I'm so
out on that I can't believe they're
doing a Space Jam one sucked I mean it's
no rad don't get me wrong
thank you thank you Spacey m1 was stupid
[ __ ] Michael Jordan playing basketball
the Bugs Bunny who gives a [ __ ] kids did
I thought it was cool for like a kid any
kid that like that movie is an idiot
everyone
this room besides do you like this that
little girl like welcome [ __ ] you
I should go see 99 degrees tonight for
24 bandar them doing that even worse I
don't know how that could be worse that
is how that could be worse that is
exactly how that could be worse there is
to recover man dude I mean like how bad
are the sons I mean how many hi pics you
gotta get to work out I mean dude I knew
this guy Aidan he's good but he's not a
[ __ ] game changer dude he's not a
game changer there's still the worst
team to lead I mean it's unbelievable to
me how like they've nothing's changed
you can't keep getting these
one-and-done guys man you got to get
some veterans in there man you got to
get some character people not these
[ __ ] one-and-done like what right
Rutley guys yeah Berkeley is playing
really old I was on a nice rant and just
[ __ ] on my birthday cake um who's this
Devin Booker like he's good he's really
I don't like how he looks physically
yeah I mean he's got like a weird kind
of [ __ ] what was that band that would
sing it with the the waves they called a
piano keyboard guitar key guitar guitar
kita what's that been smash them bricks
times and evil haircut right look at
that so bad but he's got a hundred and
fifty million dollars they gave a
hundred and fifty million dollars to a
guy know when they have their red hats
on the Devo yeah there it is oh you mean
the hats not the archive yeah
I'm adding production I'm not just a
guess Wow now we can't be on you I can
look at now we can't do it on you too
now daddy's got kicked off just [ __ ] on
everything um yeah they're just horrible
dude they have so much talent and they
just get these guys from Kentucky that
or Kansas that do one and Dunn's and
there's just no substance guys we got so
lucky it just dawned on me we got so
lucky Ari wasn't on skype and that girl
was here he would have traumatized oh oh
yeah
right when I said it everybody in the
room went oh my god oh Jesus what a
horrible idea
I don't accept these questions you need
to go and prepare a little bit better
logic legends you know uh Rachel texted
me earlier today like asking if Ari
would be on skype today and I didn't
know what it meant no I do
oh that's why she was asking that's
[ __ ] hilarious since this is a sports
podcast oh my god did we do see geek you
know we should just end the chivalry
well go for it we can go over one it's
fine what we can go past one guys
we're so excited to be working with our
good friends at seeking seeking for all
of your ticketing needs go to see geek
will download app yeah get the app you
don't want to be walking around with
your laptop everywhere you go get it in
the phone get the app use a code punch
drunk and that kid you $20 off uh your
ticket price I'm sober the fights coming
up I got my tickets yeah when is that
December worse oh it's a first yeah
oh that's like two weeks is it boxing
we're gonna boxing yep I'm super stoked
what do you think wins that fight
I mean I'm room for both of them
way to go man you can't sell tickets so
I bought it too early god dammit sell
yours and restart buy these and try save
get some money back yeah yeah any
concert you sure you you probably could
have gotten paid by CQC 98 degrees yeah
you think I could get tickets to the
Creed dracco fight yeah you could get no
concerts comedy shows play the Creed
concert
that's the Vols you name it you know I
mean dude I UC geek all the time
actually my friend texted me the other
day that she used our code oh really I
love that somebody hit me up on Twitter
and said they just did and you know it
rates tickets for you buy best value
worst value it makes ticket purchasing
look at that all greezy
as possible all your tickets are
guaranteed what's that no money all the
tickets are guaranteed you don't have to
worry about getting swindled you don't I
know I've been ripped off a ton times
when I try to scalp I have a once I've
been ripped off never once I got
swindled once I was why you got twice
twice I did with the old deal ticket
that's already been scanned and then
bought it and then I went in there like
no you can't oh my god ha you just said
he was arrested
you got your resume agents at the venue
oh my god well guess what you do that
with our friends at seeking money so
cool
yeah Johnny doesn't dude you get [ __ ]
arrested by federal agents look at you
you're like you but now you're I'm just
saying there's $1 to get an eye on he
doesn't play by the rules
Johnny waterboarding you're committing
mail for all of your ticketing needs
concerts yeah really
here I got see Keeks tag line you ready
see geek we're not a bunch of queers try
to pop Oh Oh would you do that now I
gotta feel the question about that what
trying to help him out no you're not
move some tickets baby yeah this is 2018
man you need catchphrases you do need
catchphrases 2018 that I will give you
let's go catch me your mother leading
from them is the catchphrase I don't
believe so
no Chad don't make fun of sponsors
that's our rule I've done it enough are
there a lot of tickets left for this
Johnny for this big Wilder and Tyson
Fury fight yeah for like 15 bucks you
can relax where's this that Staples
Center heavyweight division very
exciting right now because la is a
terrible sports town and they price
themself out by making it really I
guarantee you these tickets will go down
like two weeks and when they tickets go
down there's no better place to get them
done see keek who's the main event that
is the main event Tyson Fury and Deonte
well I'm so pestered for 17 bucks you
can be the corner man
that's not bad yeah and really if you
use the code punched punch-drunk you get
out it's pretty you be at the corner man
for free it'd be fun to be a corner man
I think you got the q-tips yep I'd love
to do that one time
I wanna come down the aisle with someone
God look at the transformation that
Tyson Fury has had in his body that's
when he just didn't give a damn anymore
on the right it's called p90 box no he
pretty much quit and then kind of
decided he wanted to make another
comeback and even let himself go that
much yeah he was on Rogen's podcast
talking about how he lost 150 pounds
this is the first time I've seen him and
so he's a white guy yeah actually a
gypsy is actually a gypsy yeah you know
what you should do you should just get
shredded like one last time just
shredded you know I'm saying I've been
thinking about it
you should get on aghgh bu I would do
that in a whole I'm not hard look at
Stallone he's 71 and he's jacked up I
want to look like scholar like yeah I
like competitions cuz then we we all
read it yeah we all would I want to do I
don't know if you would would you even
participate uh I wasn't really listening
to you but I'm just gonna crank we say
no I'm gonna blankly say knowledge like
the sober October what is that real
look at this [ __ ] guy 71 that's not
no that's what he looks like dude the
problem is he doesn't have those tats
you're gonna look really but the problem
is he slice and dice his face so much
yeah that puffer face he looks but he
clearly has that likes roided-out body
has the look of a guy who said put the
lotion in the basket and he's wearing
somebody skin over his skull he's in
production to film the last Rambo right
now that's true yeah
is that what's called yeah last blood
kids will never understand how great
Sylvester Stallone impressions were
never understand it ever I mean these
all these all these [ __ ] my
celebrities are all like look at this
bill look at his belt yeah he's got a
belt like Ari
I'd hang out with Stallone of course you
would totally in this photo he's at the
Grove and he sees Mario Lopez he's like
hey and then they show each other that's
that's something that only happened at a
98 degrees concert do get Stallone on
the podcast
what was the demographics at this
concert last night it was like roomful
of you it was all like I'm gonna go guys
there was like one group of like
legitimate senior citizens though that
me and Kelly could not figure out we're
like relatively grandmas we're like
migrant my mom wanted me where was it at
the Fonda well turn the will turn oh
there was a lot of like bachelorette
parties too so it's like how do you play
it out now would that be a bachelorette
party on a Sunday night a lot of
shocking gay men a lot of gay men yeah
that's I knew that because half game in
yeah the guy next to me was looks like
my neighbor rather large he was like
holding his heart the whole time like
singing oh no no 143 those are way more
expensive than I paid that's yeah that's
a red deal yeah that's red is half mine
was $29 with tax and everything oh my
god Sophie
oh my god that's not even like the front
row oh and then security would not let
these 40 year old women touch their
hands they would get booted away from
the stage as if it was like good ol I
can put their hands on like that yeah
the security I thought you meant touch
my own hand I was like what does that
even mean
yeah they can't clap yeah poor poor
women just wanted to touch Nick Lachey
we're gonna love taking calls take your
calls go to the phones doesn't Jeb is it
yeah oh there you go
Jeb you're on the line is this you
cousin Jeb what I don't know there we go
sounds like you're in a vacuum cleaner
you sound good Jeb but so what's up
buddy hello this is going well they say
me yeah I'll tell you things [ __ ] no no
listen Venus I don't even know I get it
I'm with you on this I don't know I get
more concerned every time he calls you
wait why you what does he live there
yeah oh absolutely
he loves where you live I know he just
met Theo because he Instagram or tweeted
a photo of him do that conversation
actually have Jeb on his podcast that
should be he should be like his Robin
Quivers hey hey man hey man trying to
get one of these [ __ ] to suck my dick
at my new job over at the donut shop
yeah man we'll just wish you the best
with that fella
still on the phone keep you in my
prayers you know youngster getting that
hustle on one of the greatest people
ever I like them all right have we done
our show I feel like we have I think we
closed we got empty Kumi a and Ryan
Sickler on the show from the legendary
Opie and Anthony program cool Mia he has
a show on the compound media network I
do it every time I'm in New York he's a
funny funny dude and Ryan Sickler is one
of the best comics out there yep
everybody don't forget get tripolis
special out right now and also please uh
good check out our good friend wines
siccolas new special that just came out
and album oh comedy album and have you
really said all things comedy
independent I don't know both so I will
say Happy Thanksgiving everybody have a
safe happy holiday and suck it I need
$1,000 you do need $1,000